it's kind of scary because i only  realized this a couple of days ago and i  only come out to a few people  i'm a guy  i told my mom today  and i have to go home every day  and be called my dead name  and have she her pronouns used every  time i go home  and no one realizes how hurtful it is  and i was afraid i was gonna get thrown  out of the house she realized a a couple  of days ago that she's a guy so she's  been  a girl um her whole life to this point  then a couple days ago she realized you  know what i'm a guy and  already it's hurtful if her parents  continue to see her as  the girl that that they they birthed and  have raised but she thinks she could go  home and say hey by the way everything  you've ever known about me is completely  wrong  um and you must immediately adapt to  what i am saying right now and if you  don't it is devastatingly hurtful it  wasn't yesterday but it is today